a fox news alert the president of abc
has now announced that whoopi goldberg
has been suspended for two weeks from
the view laura trump is sticking with us
on this particular issue let's get your
initial reaction i'm
you know i've i know whoopi i'll go to
my points in a second i want to get your
initial reaction laura
well i heard you at the top of the show
sean say that you didn't believe that
you know she should be suspended and we
know what the the calls would be if if
the shoe were on the other foot if it
was somebody on fox news for example who
had said something like this every uh
media outlet out there every democrat
out there would be calling for their
suspension but you know what i i think
you were very kind to say that it is
nice to see that people are taking this
seriously because look whoopi goldberg
is a very influential person she reaches
millions of people every single day what
she said was flat out wrong it sounded
maybe she didn't intend it to sound this
way very anti-semitic and very hateful
um and so although she came out and
corrected herself and apologized i think
it's nice for once to see that perhaps a
step has been taken by an outlet that uh
that we know
otherwise kind of lets people get away
with these things if they uh if they
agree with them politically so
interesting to see this outcome and and
quite frankly i'm happy to see them
taking some sort of action
and let's get your take joe contra back
with us this breaking news abc if you
missed it just suspended whoopi goldberg
over her comments on the holocaust
you know look
i've done this my whole career joe and i
and people have pressured me and and
some people get angry with me hannity
you know that they would do that to any
conservative why do you say
why do you why do you not support
boycotts why do you never call for
cancellation or firing i said well i
think her apology's sincere i think
she's learned a lot in the process um if
two weeks off is the penalty it's better
than being cancelled and i just i have a
just a reflexive reaction to cancel
because i don't like what somebody says
because you don't have to watch the view
i hate to tell you i don't watch the
view
reaction
i i yeah i'm not surprised you don't
watch the view
look you've been very consistent on this
sean the transcripts show it that you
never call for anybody to be canceled
that in the past you've always said that
people deserve second chances
i think that this is a good compromise
in terms of what you're calling for and
what others are calling for in terms of
whoopi goldberg being outright fired
right uh because the suspension at least
there's accountability for her words
that offended so many people i mean the
backlash on this has been incredible uh
it should be noted that whoopi goldberg
she resigned with abc just a few months
ago four year deal goes into seven
figures uh so there's a business aspect
to this in terms of not firing her but
but staffers were particularly upset
about those comments uh they felt they
were bad enough and then her explanation
on colbert last night uh what made
things even worse uh so look it it
should be underscored the one quote that
she had that i think really ticked
people off is this is white people doing
it to white people so this is you all go
fight amongst yourselves i mean on a
program where some truly craptastic
things are said this actually stands out
and whoopi said this isn't about race i
mean well this was hitler's entire
insidious argument right germanic people
are superior jews are an inferior race
therefore justified genocide six million
people systematically murdered so abc i
think makes the right move here
suspender for two weeks
show people that you care that words do
have consequences whoopi comes back and
maybe she is better for it and should be
noted by the way also sean uh that the
view in 25 years and having dozens upon
dozens of hosts have had exactly two
jewish co-hosts and not one in six years
just saying you know i i look at this
whole controversy though and then you
can bring joe rogan back into it laura
and in the case of joe rogan i don't
think he should have apologized joe
rogan made a decision with his doctor on
how to treat
uh covert 19 when he contracted the
virus okay
he threw everything they had at it
monoclonals hcq ivermectin that was him
between him and his doctor he gets the
crappie out of him then he interviews
the guy that was pivotal in creating the
mrna technology that led to the fisa
modern vaccines that every liberal loves
but he would use it
he would be more restrictive in its use
for older people people with
co-morbidities obesity etc okay that's
one doctor's opinion and people want to
shut them down called disinformation uh
is there anybody that has given more
false information than fauci than biden
than jensaki then walensky then the cdc
then the nih because they are the
biggest misinformers in this entire
pandemic
well and that's why no one trusts them
at this point you know it used to be in
america that people came to the table
there was a place for public discourse
where you could share ideas and you
didn't have to always agree with
someone's idea but or their thought or
their their opinion about things but at
least you got to hear that and perhaps
it got you to think a little bit and you
know what i agree with you i don't think
joe rogan should have apologized at all
i don't know that he did anything wrong
and to your point this was a doctor on
there a guy that was very pivotal in
developing these vaccines and has a lot
of knowledge of this subject so if
you're putting a lot of weight in
someone like dr fauci who has proven
himself time and time and time again to
be wrong about just about everything why
can't joe rogan have someone on his show
and just let this guy share his opinion
there should be no reason we have to
have disclaimers my gosh there's
disclaimers on everything in life now so
much so that no one even pays attention
to them anymore
it's absolutely pointless um but it
would be nice if we could get back to a
place where everyone could equally share
their opinion no matter their political
views no matter what you think or you
don't know what their political view is
that's what america is all about let's
go back and play whoopi's original
comments on the view that led to this
suspension just announced
okay i feel
being black when we talk about race it's
a very different thing to me so i said
that i i felt that the holocaust wasn't
about race
and people got very very very angry and
still are angry i mean i'm getting
you know all of the
the mail from folks and
the very real anger because people feel
very differently
but i thought it was
a
salient discussion because
as a black person i think of race as
being something that i can see
so i see you and i know what race you
are
then let's be truthful about it because
the holocaust isn't about race
no
no it's not about
but it's it's not about race
it's not about races because
it's about man's inhumanity to man
that's what it's about but it's about
white supremacy
but it's not it's not about ideology
but these are two white groups of people
how do we have to blame
him as white
it people down this alley
you know
joe as i watched first her i thought it
was very inarticulate the appearance on
on colbert it was it was a sloppy try
attempt at cleaning it up but our
original comments there's no bigger
supporter and my entire career of israel
than i have been and on virulent
anti-semitism we better pay attention to
it because it's real and it's all around
the entire world at this point it's a
real danger to the state of israel our
closest ally in the middle east
and
and she recognized the evil
but did she not know the history
or did she just negate the history she
recognized evil man's inhumanity to man
um six million jews were slaughtered
millions of others slaughtered i wrote a
book about evil i i wrote
directly about the the evils of the
holocaust and and how jews were
exterminated in nazi germany what are
you what are your thoughts we have a
minute
sure and it's not like they were
exterminated immediately they were work
to the bone to the point where when they
were no longer productive in terms of
working at those holocaust camps if
you've actually read about it then they
were exterminated i mean that's how
horrible it was so
whoopi goldberg's i guess
you know study of
the holocaust must have been seeing
schindler's list 30 years ago but here's
an idea for people on tv in general stop
making comparisons to the holocaust stop
comparing modern politicians like donald
trump to hitler because you know nothing
about how horrible it was and when you
make those comparisons it's an insult to
every single surviving family member
that knows somebody who was lost in the
holocaust and all those jews six
millions that were killed that's all i
gotta say you know what in the last
century we lost 100 million human souls
mao china stalin russia hitler
fascism you name it
a lot of evil and uh we'll be out for
two weeks more i'm steve ducey i'm brian
kill me and i'm ainsley earhart and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis